you can watch all previous afterwords
programs on our website at book TV org
[Applause]
good evening everybody thank you all so
much for coming out and braving the
rainy evening here I'm Lissa Muscatine
I'm one of the co-owners of politics in
prose bookstore thank you thank you
as you know we have a very treasured in
our view and long wonderful partnership
with our friends here at sixth and I we
host some of our favorite author events
in this beautiful beautiful space and so
I just want to thank Esther and Jacqui
and all of the people here so please
give them a hand they are doing an
incredible job with this wonderful
wonderful space and and we share with
them a real mission to strengthen and
build our community here in DC it's such
a pleasure to host gloria steinem this
evening as you know she'll be talking
about her new book it's called my life
on the road we were counting up her
previous books and you know they're a
bunch of bestsellers on the list we
think this is her seventh but it sort of
depends how you count but in any case
she's very prolific obviously and once
you read this I'm sure you're you're
going to find it as compelling and
engaging as her writing always is now to
do a proper introduction of Gloria
Steinem would take up the entire hour
which I don't think you want to want me
to do and that's because of the number
of causes she's championed the advocacy
group she's conceived and nurtured the
articles and essays and book she's
written speeches she's given campaign
she's organized magazines she's launched
and the awards she has won so I'm just
gonna mention a few of the top
highlights I think everybody in the room
knows she was the co-founder of MS
magazine in 1972 and it's editor for
many years
she founded the National Women's
Political caucus so if you're old enough
you'll know that that was one of the
first politically centered advocacy
groups for women and in 2013 and this is
pretty amazing and totally deserved she
received the nation's highest civilian
honor the Presidential Medal of Freedom
and it was awarded by President Obama
perhaps less quantifiable but no less
important is the sheer impact of her
words and ideas on the political and
social discourse of our country over
more than five decades in her new book
my life on the road it's really one
story told through many stories about
her life's journeys and I say journeys
not journey on purpose
the road she's traveled the people she's
met the books she's read the ideas she's
considered from an itinerant childhood
to her eventual discovery of what a real
home means and that was fairly late in
life she's of course a wonderful writer
a superb storyteller and a woman whose
willingness to speak truth to power has
given backbone over half a century to
the fight for the rights of women people
of color the poor children and pretty
much everyone on society's margins like
many of you in the audience tonight I
suspect I grew up on MS magazine and
thanks to Gloria Steinem I have proudly
labeled myself a feminist ever since
[Applause]
I know that I'm not alone Gloria and
very deeply appreciating that you have
literally spent your entire life giving
voice to the aspirations and ambitions
of hundreds of millions of women
worldwide and by extension their
families their communities their
countries and and really all of us so
thank you so much for being such an
inspiration
tonight glory will be in conversation
with another of our nation's most
influential advocates and activists
Maxine Waters now in her 13th term in
the US House of Representatives and
representing a diverse and fascinating
district in South Central Los Angeles
congressman Waters has earned a
reputation over her career for being
fearless outspoken relentless and above
all effective she was an unstoppable
agent of change and I remember this I
grew up in California during more than a
decade in the California State Assembly
where she fought for the divestment of
state pension funds from South Africa
and worked to protect affirmative action
she's been the same determined leader in
Congress and in the National Democratic
Party a true champion of equality and
social justice and if you've had a
chance already to read the book you'll
learn that Maxine Waters and Gloria
Steinem actually first crossed paths at
a seminal event back in 1977 the
National Women's Conference in Houston
let's just say the world has never been
the same since and for the better so
please join me in welcoming Gloria
Steinem and Congressman Maxine Waters
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you could all we need something powers
well this is the beginning of another
book is all I can say you have to
promise me do you all know each other in
this room I feel that that I mean
there's so many people I know and Maxine
knows and our work we have to organize
tonight all right so we're gonna talk
for a bit but half the time belongs to
you so this is you know trouble is going
to result from the fact that we work
together tonight but this is a
conversation so Maxine well Gloria and I
have a lot to talk about
but we can't talk about it in front of
all of you Gloria Steinem changed my
life I met her in 1977 as was said at
that wonderful conference that we had in
Houston I'd never seen anybody like
Gloria Steinem in Bella Abzug and Bella
Abzug was one of Gloria's dearest
friends in life she loved her so much
and Bella shouted in her all the time
and I finally said to go in well why do
you let her talk to you that way and
Gloria said this is the way we talk to
each other New York no I remember that
so clearly because Maxine we did not
know each other and Bella really was
shouting at me you know as if you know
Bella you knew that she just shouted at
you about how terrible something was and
you waited until she finished and then
you explained why you did it and she
said oh well maybe you're right now she
will
and I could see Maxine looking appalled
and I did say this is just the way we
talk in New York which isn't actually
true but I was trying to comfort her and
so you know at the conference many of us
were there not knowing what we were
supposed to do and how we were supposed
to do it and so as a few days went by we
started to try and organize and I got
involved with organizing the minority
caucus and we said we had a lot to say
but we didn't really know how to write
it so glory was drafted to write
everything for everybody and we dictated
to her much of what we wanted to say and
not only did I get a chance to do the
preamble as the book states you know to
the minority plank but the most
wonderful thing was following that she
asked me to join the board of MS
foundation the idea and I was a member
of the California State Assembly at that
time and all of the ideas that I had
about trying to create opportunities for
women becoming a feminist I took those
ideas to the California State
Legislature and I was able to get many
of them signed into law and one that
I'll just share with you was at the time
that I was in the California State
Assembly insurance companies would not
pay for the build up after mastectomy
they said it was cosmetic surgery but
now I was a feminist I wasn't going for
that and so because of my being able to
serve on the board and witness all of
these proposals that came in unsolicited
I've learned to move on things like that
and of course I had it signed into law
but my life changed because of Gloria
Steinem and I ended up in New York every
month or so and met so many different
people and
gloria was you know i had not met such a
woman before in my life and here was
this woman who was young who I thought
should have been a model and here she
was organizing and working and she was
way outside of the box she was dating a
black man and so and so we had these
wonderful wonderful times together and
we reminisced a lot about what we were
going to do later on in life and here we
are later on in life and we have not
organized the village yet where we're
all going to end up staying but this
book this book that Gloria has written
really does tell you who she is what she
cares about and the experiences that
she's had it's wonderful reading I won't
tell you anymore say much more about it
except Gloria doesn't know what impact
she had on my life in so many ways and
the stories she told I remember them all
and when I read about her mother in this
book it was just like talking to Gloria
all over again and she explained to me
what had happened in her life with her
mom so Thank You Gloria
no thank you and you know Maxine has
always been in the forefront we haven't
planned this conversation right but just
now I was thinking about your struggle
in California to keep the cops from
doing internal searches of women that
they stopped for traffic reasons okay
right and there was just such another
story in the press from another state
but what we have discovered about the
mistreatment of women what we what black
lives matter is saying what you know
Maxine has always been
there and if any other woman wins the
presidency it will be because Maxine and
barbara Lee and Barbara Mikulski you
know you know all the people who have
been out there proving that women can be
respected in authority in public life it
will be because all of those women and
Maxine especially in so many ways have
demonstrated that women's Authority in
public life is okay is normal is good is
positive because otherwise I think we're
so used to seeing women only in
child-rearing women too you know where
we associate female authority with
nurturing and emotion and things inside
the home we see male authority as
rational and appropriate to affairs
outside the home and you know I think
that's part of the reason that it's hard
for some women to and especially for men
I think about it when I see the some of
the grown up guys on television saying
ridiculous things about well I'm
thinking about 2008 now when Hillary
Clinton you know took all this [ __ ] you
know and the you know big grown-up news
guys were saying I crossed my legs when
I see her she reminds me of my first
wife waiting outside the alimony court I
mean hello and I think in a way they
felt regressed to childhood because that
was the last time they thought they saw
and a woman in authority so you know
Maxine has so helped to change that to
open up a space for female talent of all
kinds in public life and I'm just so
grateful for that now the problem is we
don't get to see each other enough so we
have to we're really here
you know as I said I started my trips to
New York because of MS and met wonderful
women and I could recall I could but I
won't
all of many of the meetings that we had
talked about Marlo Marlo Thomas in those
meetings and free to be I remember all
of that that Gloria supported and we had
some very very talented women who were
true feminist and I want to tell you you
might be a little bit surprised but for
me to identify myself as a feminist back
in the day
the black woman said what are you
talking about you can't be a feminist
that's a white woman's thing this is so
wrong to me black women invented
feminism doesn't unfortunately I know
but all of that gets destroyed but I
think people would like to hear about
some of these trips I had just an
opportunity to a read part of the the
preface here and I think the story that
you told about being in this place where
the bikers okay all right and it's so
wonderfully written and it is so
absolutely educational about how you
must not think about people based on
what you think you see but if you just
stop and talk with folks you can learn
an awful lot could you show that yeah I
think the road is my substitute for
meditation you know all my friends tell
me that I should meditate mindfulness
I've taken courses I never do it okay
but I think that's partly because the
road is my form of it it forces you to
live in the present it forces you to be
you know alive with all your senses and
to question all your sub positions so I
will I will read this which is the
prelude to the book and then then I have
another section which is supposed to
lead us into organizing but we can wait
for a while I board a plane for Rapid
City South Dakota and see a lot of
people in black leather chains and
tattoos airline passengers usually look
like where they're going business suits
to Washington DC jeans to LA but I can't
imagine a convention of such
unconventional visitors in Rapid City is
the kind of town where people still
angle parked their cars in front of the
movie Palace my bearded seatmate is
asleep in his studded jacket and nose
ring so I just accept one more mystery
of the road at the airport I meet five
female friends from different parts of
the country we are a diverse group of
women a Cherokee activist and her
grown-up daughter who's here
Rebecca Adamson who was the Cherokee
activist okay two african-american
writers and one musician and me we've
been invited to a Lakota Sioux powwow
celebrating the powerful place that
women held before patriarchy arrived
from Europe and efforts now to restore
that place as we drive toward the
badlands we see an acre of motorcycles
around each isolated diner and motel
this solves the mystery of the leather
and the chains but it creates another
when we stop for coffee our waitress
can't believe that we don't know every
August since 1938 bikers from all over
the world have come here for a rally
named after Sturgis a town that just a
wide place in the road
they are drawn by the sparsely populated
space of forests mountains and a grid of
highways so straight that it is
recognizable from outer space right now
about 250,000 bikers are filling every
motel and campground within 500 miles
our band of six strong women takes note
the truth is we are a little afraid of
so many bikers in one place how could we
not be we have learned from movies that
the bikers travel in packs treat women
like possessions and may see other women
as sexual fair game but we don't run
into the bikers because we spend our
days traveling down unmarked roads past
the last stand of trees in Indian
country we eat home-cooked food brought
in trucks sit on blankets around powwow
grounds we're dancers follow the
heartbeat of drums and watch Indian
ponies as decorated as the dancers when
it rains a rainbow stretches from can't
see to can't see and fields of wet sweet
grass become as fragrant as gigantic
flowers only when we return late each
night to our cabins do we see
motorcycles in the parking lot while
walking in Rapid City I hear a biker say
to his tattooed woman partner honey
shop as long as you want I'll meet you
at the cappuccino place
I assume this is an aberration on our
last morning I enter the lodge alone for
an early breakfast trying to remain both
inconspicuous and open-minded still I'm
hyper conscious of a room full of knife
sheaths jackboots
and very few women in the booth next to
me a man with chains around his muscles
and a woman in leather pants and an
improbable hairdo are taking note of my
presence finally the woman comes over to
talk I just want to tell you she says
cheerfully how much miss magazine has
meant to me my husband he reads some now
that he's retired but what I wanted to
ask isn't one of the women you're
traveling with Alice Walker I love her
poetry it turns out that she and her
husband have been coming to this
motorcycle rally every year since they
were first married
she loves the freedom of the road and
also the mysterious moon scape of the
Badlands she urges me to walk there but
to follow the paths marked by ropes
during the war over the sacred Black
Hills she explains Lakota warriors found
refuge there because the cavalry got
lost every time her husband said stops
by on his way to the cashier and
suggests I see the huge statue of Crazy
Horse that's being dynamited out of the
Black Hills Crazy Horse riding his pony
he says is going to make all those
Indian killing presidents in on Mount
Rushmore look like nothing
he walks away a gentle Lovering
lumbering man tattoos chains and all
before she leaves my new friend tells me
to look out the big picture window at
the parking lot see that purple Harley
out there the big gorgeous one that's
mine I used to ride behind my husband
and never took the road on my own then
after the kids were grown I put my foot
down it was hard but we finally got to
be partners now he says he likes it
better this way he doesn't have to worry
about his bike breaking down or getting
a heart attack and totaling us both I
even put miss on my license plate
and you should see my grandkids faces
when Grandma rides up on her purple
Harley on my own again I look out at the
barren sand and tortured rocks of the
Badlands stretching for miles I've
walked there and I know that close up
the barren sand reveals layers of pale
beige and rose and cream and the rocks
turn out to have intricate womb-like
openings even in the distant cliffs
caves of rescue appear what seems to be
one thing from a distance is very
different close up I tell you this story
because it's the kind of lesson that can
be learned only on the road and also
because I've come to believe that inside
each of us has a purple motorcycle we
have only to discover it when ride
[Music]
I thought you'd enjoy that also I loved
it but even more than the actual story
and the lesson that's taught in the
story the way Gloria writes is so
wonderful and the descriptive nature of
her writing as she describes the
landscape and all of those things is
just so wonderful and easy reading it's
like you know you're talking to her and
so I know she had some other things that
she wanted to read but I really wanted
you to hear that okay well shall I read
my organizing thing and then we can all
start talking to each other okay all
right wait a minute let me see if I have
to find it I've decided okay
all the years of campaigning have given
me one clear message voting isn't the
most we can do but it is the least to
have a democracy you have to want one
still I realize this fully only by
looking back at the beginning of the
1980s I went to Missouri to campaign for
Harriet woods in her US Senate race I
bet there are people here remember
Harriet would think she was a great
candidate and her path into politics was
so improbable that no one could have
made it up as a mother of two young
children she complained about a noisy
manhole cover that awakened them every
time a car rolled over it when she got
nowhere with the City Council
she circulated a neighborhood petition
to close the street to cars it worked
this success led her to run for the City
Council she won
served eight years got appointed to the
State Highway Commission ran a
successful race for the state
legislature and was re-elected there too
all this made her a viable candidate
statewide still this was not enough for
the state Democratic Party it's gonna
sound familiar too when it came time to
choose a primary candidate in the US
Senate race it backed a well-to-do
banker who had never run for anything
but who had written checks but she
turned out to have something more
important than her party's blessing
community support and volunteers she
beat the rich guy two-to-one suddenly
Harriet woods was in a race with
Republican Senator John Danforth he was
not only the incumbent but a former
Attorney General of Missouri and
ordained Episcopal priest and the rich
grandson of the founder of Ralston
Purina It was as if she were running
against the entire patriarchy
when I went to campaign for her I could
see that all the new feminist electoral
groups were working their hearts out and
they were volunteering in her statewide
campaign though Missouri was often
counted as an anti-choice State Woods
refused to budge from her support for
reproductive freedom as a fundamental
human right in the end she won in rural
Republicans area areas anyway including
one so conservative that it was known as
a little Dixie but in the final week she
had run out of money and couldn't answer
the last minute storm a virulent attacks
she lost by less than two percent of the
vote it was so clear that she could have
won with money to answer those
last-minute attacks that her race
inspired the founding of Emily's list
[Music]
and this pack went on to attract 3
million members and become one of the
biggest in the nation as well as the
single biggest resource for women in
politics but but Danforth did win he
took with him to Washington an
african-american lawyer named Clarence
Thomas who had been working for Monsanto
the agrochemical giant that gave us
Agent Orange genetically engineered
seeds and more indeed Danforth got him
that job at Monsanto - as Danforth
explained he was very attracted to
Thomas not only because he was a rare
African American conservative but also
because he too had studied to be a
priest in his case a Catholic priest all
this happened decades ago yet the impact
of her loss by a few hundred votes goes
on if you don't believe me flash forward
to the morning after the 2000 Bush vs.
gore presidential election with national
results hanging by the thread of a few
thousand disputed votes in Florida I
just happened to be speaking at Palm
Beach County Community College that
morning its campus just happened to be
in a poor area and therefore a
democratic area and I could see that
nobody wanted to talk about anything but
the election that was hanging by a
thread that morning a young African
American woman rose to say that she had
registered to vote by phone than been
challenged by her polling place because
Caucasian had been printed next to her
name she never did get to vote an older
African American man said he had been
denied the right to vote because he was
told he had a felony conviction yet he'd
never been accused of a crime much less
convicted someone shouted out yes you
have it's called voting while black amid
the laughter another man stood to
explain that names of people with
felonies had been merged with the voter
rolls without checking whether more than
one person shared the same name then an
older white woman said said the bus from
her retirement home had been sent to the
wrong polling place others testified
that polling places were fewer and lines
were longer in poor and more democratic
areas people had given up because they
were hourly workers who lost pay if they
weren't at their jobs then a white man
of 50 or so said he'd seen the
illustration of the ballot box only on
the way out and realized he had
accidentally voted for an extreme
right-wing candidate when he thought he
was voting for Al Gore painful memories
for what that caused a dozen more people
to groan and shout that this had also
happened to them out of approximately
700 people in that one auditorium at
least a hundred had been unable either
to vote for their chosen candidate or to
vote at all I wondered if there are this
many in one auditorium how many in all
of Palm Beach
County how many in all the state of
Florida
finally a white man of 30 or so
rows to face me in the name of his
military service to his country he said
and also in the name of his young
daughter whom he wanted to grow up in a
democracy
he asked will you stay and help us
organize a protest tomorrow and the next
day in the next whatever it takes I
could feel a deep pull to say yes yet I
thought my presence might be used to
call this a rebellion instigated by an
outsider
instead I promised to take the name
address and polling place of everyone
who had not been able to vote at all or
had voted for for a candidate they
didn't know they were voting for and
give them to lawyers for Gore as well as
nonpartisan watch dogs outside the state
I went home I called the election
lawyers I delivered the lists as
promised
when Bush's lead was down to a mere 537
votes out of 6 million cast the
reexamine agree examination of ballots
was stopped Florida's Secretary of State
Katherine Harris also the co-chair of
Bush's Florida campaign declared Bush
the winner calls for a recount were
deafening and supported by the Florida
Supreme Court however the US Supreme
Court ruled five to four that there was
no uniform recount standard to meet the
Equal Protection Clause and no time to
create one it was a decision that would
be compared with the Dred Scott decision
the 19th centuries of Supreme Court
ruling that no black person slave or
free could ever become a citizen of the
United States for its impact and for its
clear of bias now remember for want of a
nail the horseshoe was lost for want of
a horseshoe the horse was lost for one
of them horse the battle was lost and so
on this parable should be the mantra of
anyone who think
that his or her vote doesn't count if
Harriet woods hadn't been defeated by
less than two percent of the votes in
Missouri Danforth
wouldn't have been a u.s. senator if
Danforth hadn't been a Senate senator
Clarence Thomas wouldn't have gone with
him to Washington as a staff member if
Thomas hadn't been visible in Washington
as a rare african-american who opposed
his community's majority views he
wouldn't have been appointed by the
first President Bush to head and to
disempower the Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission and then to sit
on the DC Court of Appeals if Thomas
hadn't been given such credentials he
couldn't have been nominated by the same
President Bush to succeed the great
civil rights advocate Justice Thurgood
Marshall on the Supreme Court if Thomas
hadn't been on the Supreme Court
he couldn't have supplied the one vote
margin that halted the Florida recount
if there had been a recount
Al Gore not george w bush would have
been president as was concluded by a
post-election examination of all
uncounted ballots that was commissioned
by twelve major news organizations if
george w bush had not been president the
united states would have been less
likely to lose the world sympathy after
9/11 by launching the longest war in US
history with more bombs dropped on
afghanistan during 14 years than in all
of world war 2 plus billions in tax
dollars given to 20,000 private
contractors and thousands killed and
wounded on both sides if al gore not
george w bush had been president global
warming would have been taken more
seriously also the United States would
not have falsified evidence to justify
invading oil-rich Iraq thus starting an
eight-year war and together with
Afghanistan convincing some in Islamic
countries
the United States was waging war on
Islam without george w bush there would
not be the biggest transfer of wealth
into private hands in the history of
this nation a pay ratio in which the
average CEO earns four hundred and
seventy times more than the average
worker in canada it's only 20 times more
an executive order giving an estimated
40 billion in tax dollars to Catholic
evangelical and other religious groups
without congressional approval often
with the appearance of turning churches
into a vote delivery system without
Clarence Thomas to supply the one vote
majority the spirit the Supreme Court
might not have ruled that corporations
are people with the right to unlimited
political spending in order to continue
all of the above well you get the idea
the list goes on we must not only vote
we must fight to vote the voting booth
really is the one place on earth where
the least powerful
and the most powerful are equal I still
dream about that veteran and his
daughter I so wish I had said yes I have
no idea whether we in the room could
have made a difference in truth we don't
know which of our acts in the present
will shape the future but we have to
behave as if everything we do matters
because it might
so questions answers let's see we have
two mics here right as you can you don't
have to ask a question you can give us
really you can give us an answer we
could use answers you can make
organizing announcements of any upcoming
trouble making me think this group
should know about so I do a lot of
abortion storytelling work I had an
abortion I tell a lot of people about it
it's been awkward but you do too and so
I was wondering what your thoughts are
on sort of the newer abortion
storytelling movement 2d stigmatized
things like shout your abortion and the
one-in-three campaign and what you would
say either of you to two women who had
abortions who are thinking about you
know whether or not they can speak about
it whether they can tell them their
truth about that no I it's not my
decision it's their decision and it
seems to me that political justice
social justice movements come out of
telling the truth as much as we possibly
can
it was the issue that made me understand
that we needed a women's movement
because I went to cover an abortion
hearing before the Supreme Court ruling
and women were standing up and telling
the stories of their abortions and I had
never told the story of mine and you
know it's one in three as we all know
American women that's needed an abortion
at some time in her life it is it's it's
like the the marriage equality movement
is the LG you know it comes I just
it comes from telling the truth
respecting each other's choices telling
the truth discovering you're not alone
do you want to address
this magazine well I can recall of being
a young girl in st. Louis Missouri and
of course all my friends about the same
age 16 15 17 18 and girls were getting
pregnant and there was a midwife who was
in across the bridge as we called it in
Illinois and it became known through you
know all of our communities that this is
where you go in order to have you wound
dilated by this midwife and of course
all of those girls would end up in the
hospital infected and near-death but
I've always wondered even though I was
young why I didn't think something was
unusual about that and it was not until
many years later of course when you know
the feminist movement began to really
help women to understand that they have
a right to make choices and that they
have a right to good health care and all
of that that I thought about all of
those young women who some who died I'm
sure or who were near death and we just
considered that that's just the way life
is
we didn't travail we didn't talk about
it we didn't do anything and so when the
feminist movement began to really make
this discussion take place in this
country I always felt a little bit
guilty that I hadn't understood you know
for so many years why women had the
right to good health care why why didn't
we have the right to good health care
and why didn't we know that there was
something awfully wrong with the way
women were sneaking young girls to have
abortion and put in their lives on the
line you know I I don't want to keep
people standing whether it occurs to me
that I can't
other people to do what I don't do right
so I'll read you the dedication of this
sport dr. John this book is dedicated to
dr. John John sharp of London who in
1957 a decade before physicians in
England could legally perform an
abortion for any reason other than the
health of the woman took the
considerable risk of referring for an
abortion a 22 year old American on her
way to India knowing only that she had
broken an engagement at home to seek an
unknown fate he said you must promise me
two things first you will not tell
anyone my name second you will do what
you want to do with your life dear dr.
Sharpe I believe you who knew the law
was unjust would not mind if I say this
so long after your death I've done the
best I could with my life this book is
for you
if I'm just I'm really reading you that
just because it's true I think we I
can't ask anybody else to tell the truth
unless I have right okay but we can't
hear you with by the name of fitzy Mayer
you shaanak I have known Gloria for 61
years
oh I want to ask you whether you have
been to London to meet my cousin
Catherine Mayer the founder of the
woman's equality party for England I
mean would I have I met her no but I
obviously should okay um I actually just
well not super recently but recently
finished organizing in Arkansas and I
have to totally vouch for what you said
about bikers I was collecting weight
raise the wage petition signatures
before that actually passed in Arkansas
and the bikers during the bike blues and
barbecue thing that they have in
Fayetteville totally were into it it was
really unexpected and it was great so
actually not just a one-time thing about
bikers
but half of the things we said I was
like oh my gosh okay but my real
question is you hear a lot about war on
women you know all of the crap that's
going around right now what is the one
thing that you're most frustrated about
not having seen come to pass that you've
worked for and what's one of your most
proudest achievements that has actually
come to pass
hmm oh that's hard it's hard to pick one
thing I mean the collectively the thing
that is the most crazy making to me is
that violence against females in all
different forms whether it's son
preference or honor killings or domestic
violence in this country or forced
pregnancies and child marriage you know
violence against women in war zone
sexualized my own altogether it adds up
to the fact that for the first time that
we know of there are fewer females now
on Spaceship Earth than males and you
know that whatever form it takes in our
lives I think you know I think we're all
becoming much more aware of that now if
you ask me what is the thing I'm
proudest of that's really hard because I
live in the future
so when people ask me that I always say
I haven't done it yet
so I am the president of the mycologist
chapter for the Association for women in
mathematics so we promote math and we
promote women but we cannot post one
thing without somebody saying gee if
there's an association for women in
mathematics why isn't there an
association for men in mathematics
what would you respond the association
for men and mathematics is called
mathematics I do admit that I am so very
nervous right now
don't be we're so glad you're here you
both have been doing now because you
work for several decades now and I think
out of all of your work and all of your
accomplishments the thing that stands
out to the most is that you've been able
to push through activist fatigue since
the 60s and I'm just wondering through
all these obstacles were there moments
when you were close to quitting or
thought about quitting or considered it
somehow and what was that capture going
mmm close to quitting mm-hmm and what
kept you going I said to someone just
today that if there's one thing that
bothers me and probably motivates me to
work is unfairness I do not like people
to be treated unfairly I really truly
believe in equality
I believe in respect for you know every
human being and I am motivated to fight
you know some of those evil spirits you
see on TV
every day of my life yeah I think
actually what keeps me going is that the
only thing worse than trying whether you
succeed or not is not trying and then
you walk around wondering what if maybe
if I'd done this it would have worked it
drives you crazy so better to try yeah
hi my name is Leanne I'm gonna read this
because I was nervous that I wouldn't
have the courage to even ask this
question and as a Jewish feminist who
supports the liberation of the
Palestinian people I've been really
moved that you have spoken out in strong
critique of the Israeli government and I
would love to learn from you a little
bit more about how you navigate your
role as a Jewish woman in a Jewish
feminist in the time in history when so
much of our community is complicit in
the oppression of the Palestinian people
[Music]
you know I I haven't played a big role
in the long-term difficulties and
heartache and oppression and you know
mostly what I have done is is tried to
come together with women on all three
sides and help there to be communication
among women and what what has always
struck me is that the Palestinian women
and the Israeli peace women and American
feminists and so on I mean we worked out
the two-state solution down to the last
contract or the last agreement on water
rights you know like 25 years ago and I
the the great sadness is that unlike say
Liberia where Christian and Muslim women
came together and managed to get rid of
a warlord regime and at least have a
democratic election and unlike Ireland
where women on both sides came together
when governments couldn't it we it
hasn't it hasn't happened it hasn't
happened and it's a huge heartache
remember it's a honor for me to be able
to address you tonight I was wondering
if you could speak a little bit about
your essay Sex Lies and advertising and
talk a little bit about what the
advertising world was like when you just
uttered this
yeah the advertising is really such a
huge problem
in many ways but especially in women's
magazines because women's magazines are
regarded in the industry as cash cows as
they're called and what that means is
that the advertisers have traditionally
controlled most of the magazine paid
and that's why you see a copy that isn't
supposed to be the ad that is about the
product or the category of product it
advertising has a lot of influence
everywhere but it has I in my experience
most influence in in women's magazines
the some of us remember when there was
fiction and poetry in women's magazines
and more articles the editors of those
magazines are striving their best to
sneak in you know some independent
editorial but it's very very difficult I
think until we are willing to pay as
subscribers and not be dependent totally
on on advertising income that we are
going to have this problem they're there
if you know the educational service on
online called s called Linda asked Linda
I guess lym das lynda.com you can learn
anything for I don't know what twenty
five dollars a month and you know it's
it's a populist educational institution
no ads at all totally subscribers
supported and it's been successful for
twenty years
and Lynda Weinman who started it who has
you know a representative employee list
I mean you know everything you could
possibly want she wants to be helpful
with the US education problem so she is
stuff she sold the business for two
billion dollars okay it's possible that
we can support what we want to support
and therefore get what we want instead
of being subject to two ads that control
what we see control so much of what we
see well let me just take a moment to
tell you about a recent announcement and
it's a little bit strange
playboy just announced there will be no
more naked women
and Gloria as you know have brought them
to this point because she infiltrated
playboy many years ago but what's
interesting is the daughter of Hugh
Hefner who we've known for many years
who took over some part of the
management of that magazine some years
ago I always thought that even though
she kind of inherited that that she
wanted to do something better with the
magazine and I don't know if years later
this is her decision to try and change
the magazine I don't know if it can be
changed but I thought it was an
interesting occurrence that well it
decided no more naked women you're a
positive person Maxine I hope you're
right but what what they said was that
they were stopping this because there
was so much pornography available
everywhere right and they were doing it
for economic reasons
so some they somebody you know emailed
me a query about it I said this is like
the NRA saying we're not selling
handguns anymore because assault weapons
are so available
I hope she's right okay
I thank you for this this is incredible
and I'm a little bit shocked that I'm
speaking to Gloria Steinem so that's it
for just us here just us chickens so
much of what you've been talking about
tonight has me thinking about the
importance of knowing our history as
feminists and you also brought up the o8
election so I'm gonna be that person who
says what about 2016 looking back to
2008 I think a lot of people both in
Hillary's campaign and her supporters
had some serious trouble talking about
race especially with Barack Obama and
looking forward to 2016 we could have
another situation where Hillary isn't a
general is or another but a situation
where Hillary is in a general election
against another history-making man of
color so what lessons can we take from
what went wrong in 2008 and applied to
this possibility looking forward in this
election you know if we could just never
ask answer a question from a news
reporter saying which is more important
sex or race excuse me most people in the
world are most women are affected by
both I mean it is impossible to uproot
racism without uprooting sexism too
because to maintain racial difference
you have to control reproduction or it's
like castes in India it's the same thing
so I I hope that no matter what happens
we will be a hundred percent clear that
that race and sex are intertwined you
can only uproot them together and
absolutely refused to answer stupid
questions like which is more important
[Music]
I'm old enough to love you both
I'm very curious about what it takes to
achieve acceptance as being regular or
ordinary years ago the word Ms didn't
exist and now it's ordinary and when I
was growing up in the 50s in a small
town in Pennsylvania on our coffee table
you know with a white family house we
had life and Better Homes and Gardens
and ebony so that we got from going to
the big city Cleveland Ohio my mom and I
went to the ebony fashion shows and so
with the ticket
she got a subscription to ebony I got
jet I thought that was normal I thought
everybody probably had magazines at home
that were different races people oh so
I've kind of grown up with people of
different races being ordinary
I now see Miz as being completely
ordinary because that's I was I was I
was missed until I was out of college
but you know then came is how much does
ordinariness lead or whatever we can do
about that lead to a more general
acceptance of short that's in the way
life is
no it becomes ordinary because we do it
I mean actually miss was an old term but
to be frank we didn't know that that it
was from the I don't know 14th century
something we just found it in
secretarial handbooks for the of the
from the 50s for the disaster of not
knowing whether somebody was married or
not you know
but actually it's it's an abbreviation
that you know how they once called
little boys and girls mistress and
master and so on so it just means
mistress without marital status and it's
actually on tombstones frou-frou in the
United States from centuries ago so it
wasn't new but that's academic really
because it became ordinary just by use
you know we named the Moab Zach put a
made a bit of a congressional bill to
encourage to require the government to
supply it as a choice so it just it's
the same thing you know it comes from
saying the thing your friend saved the
thing it happens to them it makes sense
and it grows so I think that's a form of
activism making things I think that's a
form of activism yes it is it is it is
totally a form of activism I mean think
about marriage equality just the phrase
marriage equality didn't exist no not at
all right and you really didn't read it
did you
did you say Jet magazine Josh you got
jet in your house
I was really sad that it just isn't
being published anymore because yeah
like from the time I was I don't know 12
until I went to college the I grew up
with it good
hi my name is Leanne I guess in some
ways this is a follow up to an answer
that you gave just a couple of questions
ago because I would like to I guess I
like to think that the most notable
impact on my identity as a woman has
also been my identity as a woman of
color and sometimes I find those two
parts of my identity seemingly in
conflict with one another especially
when you think about feminism in the way
that it's presented in the mainstream
like for example sexual assault with the
legislative pushes that are being put
forward is most mostly impacting
colleges and military and those are both
issues that do need to be solved but in
some ways it comes into conflict with
what I see is important because Native
women where my family live on
reservations are completely unprotected
when they're assaulted both in terms of
domestic violence and raped by
non-member non-members of the tribe and
so in some ways I see what is being put
forth as the basis for a lot of these
conversations right excludes like the
issues that women that look and are just
like me have to experience on a daily
basis so I guess it's hard sometimes to
get people who look to the lena Dunham's
and to the Taylor Swift to understand
that the experiences of women are very
broad mom and so my question is first
how do we get people who adhere to
mainstream feminism to understand that
there tend to be gaps between women of
different racial and ethnic groups and
then also secondly to put that into
action mmm but you're standing up and
saying it you know that's great
and you're absolutely right you know
that the focus is on colleges not on
Indian country where the rates of sexual
assault are way worse so there's no
competition of tears you know tears are
tears we just have to keep reminding
each other to be inclusive and it's it's
not easy the same conversation is going
on in India for instance because the
rate of sexual assault and the famous
rape in New Delhi so on have to also
include the fact that judges actually
say that doll eat women that so-called
untouchable doll eat women by definition
can't be raped you know so this it's
it's always it's always our task to be
as inclusive as we possibly can and to
and to be reminded of being inclusive do
you do you have something that you want
to happen that we can help happen
I mean first I would like us to push the
Department of Justice and federal
attorneys to prosecute to actively
prosecute those non members that commit
sexual assault on reservations and also
I think secondly what would also be
important is that for valla to not
simply be about known acquaintances that
commit domestic violence against Native
women but to include a whole plethora of
crimes that occur against women on those
native reservations and they think also
making sure that the Keystone pipeline
is not built through Indian play where
more non-native men are brought to those
reservations at another buyer
right
right and and never it never failed
today I mean we all learned right now
right and also I think that the
inclusion of women in Indian country in
the Violence Against Women Act was
accomplished by one woman in the White
House or anything so you know we all
have to do it because it matters yeah
thank you but to both of you for being
here this evening
we've talked a lot about feminism it
seems that we're in the sort of space
where everyone here is identified as a
feminist there seems to have been a lot
of pushback either by public women or
women who are famous who seem to not
want to identify with that term they
called themselves humanists I think
Meryl Streep was most recently quoted
saying she's not a feminist she's a
humanist and I think anyone would look
at her and assume that she were a
feminist why do you think this would
have pushback on the label or the term
mm-hmm where do you think that comes
from how do we 12 yeah I think some
people don't say feminists because they
don't know what it means and if they go
to the dictionary and see it means of
anybody man or woman who believes in the
full service oh yeah I'm a feminist and
then some people don't say it because
they do know what it means that they're
against it you know but the the problem
with the first group is that the word is
still perceived as being anti-male
humorless and then there's the
inimitable Rush Limbaugh saying feminazi
everyday humanists actually has a
different meaning historically because
it means you believe in human potential
or possibility not in God so maybe
people like Meryl Streep I don't know
we're adding to the fact that they are
feminist by saying and they are humanist
but it I find it very painful whenever
anybody who actually believes in the
content doesn't use the word because I
don't think people would say I'm not for
civil rights you know or I don't know it
is painful what do you think we can do
to kind of change that or do you think
you should be focusing on the label
No well the more we say it it's like
everything else telling the truth the
more we say it the more we put it on
shirts this is what a feminist look like
looks like well we've come quite a quite
a distance back in the day we were bra
burners and all kind of names but that
has changed what I what I like about the
possibility of kind of revitalizing the
discussion on feminism is that young
women like yourself have the opportunity
to really not only create more
discussion more organizing more work
more involvement and I'm convinced that
that is going to happen and that you
will be by your actions defining
feminism and you'll be saying it loud
and clear I'll get right on
we have time for just a bit like it
didn't hear the beginning for two more
questions okay so two more questions oh
dear and do you have any announcements
do you have any organising announcements
that were you want to make okay I have
an organizing announcement and a
question that accompanies it so my name
is Josie Lehrer
I run a project called the men's story
project our mutual friend Michael Kimmel
is on the Advisory Council as well as
Jackson Katz and others and I want to
invite folks here to get involved it's
as well as you Gloria and congresswoman
it's it's a project where men are
getting up on public stages on college
campuses in communities and sharing
personal stories that challenge notions
of masculinity through the lens of their
own life experience and it is very much
a feminist project I'm finding that it's
very much an intersectional feminist
project so it's please talk to me it's
men's story project org and the question
that I have for you is I'm also nervous
I'm curious as to your sense of the role
of women in bringing men into feminism
and feminist activism because one of the
interesting things that I've been
finding with this project is that men
come to the men's story project events
and then they I hear that they go back
to their dorms and they're raving about
it and in tears and you know telling the
men in their lives about it and calling
their fathers on the way home and really
taking it upon themselves to spread the
word and I found that really interesting
in our evaluation study and so I'm
really curious as to your sense of a
that the role of men in advancing
women's equality and rights but then
also be women's role in getting men into
it and the project website I'll just say
if I may is a men's story project
network Thanks
I think we we need to empathize you know
we need to think okay what would help me
understand if I were on the other side
we have to start there and use examples
I mean when I'm talking to groups of men
I also I think we all do talk about the
restriction of both roles and men are
often deprived of their kids they're
deprived of developing the full human
circulatory and people to serve them
coffee but it is the president on the
list and the ability to develop all of
our human qualities is precious to us
whoever we are so you know I always and
actually links ins lengthens men's lives
I mean what have we figured out this out
that men stand to live about four years
longer if they're no longer killed by
the masculine role that is speeding and
violent deaths and so on I mean what
other movement can offer you for more
useful but I don't think that that that
women are responsible for or in charge
of figuring this out for men just I'd
like I don't think that I don't think
that African American people are latina
you know are in charge of trying to make
white people shape-up it's it's it's a
you know it's a larger human question
and I help me I always try to start out
by saying what I wish someone would say
say to me and if that doesn't work I
escalate after that but there are groups
all over this country of brave
compassionate men who are against
violence against women who are out there
you know taking big risks who are
insisting on parental leave where they
work and jeopardizing their promotions
by doing so who are saying you know I
have to go home you know because my kid
is in a play and being told they don't
have a fire in the belly that's proper
you know the two good enough to advance
them it's it's its present and I think
we become reliable allies when we see
our interest in the other person's
liberation - well I'm gonna tell you
just a little story about Marlo Thomas
that she told me it was a little joke
her husband was forever asking her where
my shoes where my shoes and finally she
said where are my shoes and so and I
think about how we relate to each other
men and women and oftentimes without
really understanding or knowing it or
thinking about it we're forever in a
position of servitude and we keep doing
things and keeping asking others by our
actions to depend on us for all kinds of
things I've started telling my husband
don't ask me about the next appointment
don't ask me about where we supposed to
be aware the vacation is know you think
about that yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
because I found that if I become a bird
it is like what are we gonna eat I don't
know what you're gonna eat but I know
what I'm getting and so I've started to
relieve myself of the responsibility to
always think about nurturing and taking
care of others even though you know
there are times and there different
things that happen in life with
certainly you use but this everyday way
of allowing yourself to be depended on
in so many ways I think keeps us from
helping men to become less you know
respectful of our independence so that
we do we do do what we see not but not
what we're told it's right so the
families we grow up in you know do do do
our kids see democratic families in
which people don't have those kind of
roles or do they not are we
we generally speaking it's okay to
imitate the powerful group but not the
other way around
so little girls maybe being raised more
like little boys but our little boys
being raised more like little girls you
know with the same freedom of expression
and the emotion mm-hmm we can do this we
can do this fantastic segue into what I
was going to ask five months ago I had a
baby
boy and had I had a girl I knew exactly
what I was going to do to raise a strong
empowered girl and part of the gift I
see of my little boy is the challenge of
how do I raise him you know in a
feminist world and to understand all of
these things and I hope that he comes
into full consciousness with Hillary
Clinton being president for a huge and
that's what to understand too in tonight
I think we're all of an age where I mean
we realized that we saw the other we
know what that life is like I want to
raise him that it's just it's normal
uh-huh you know I was just thinking when
you were saying that I mean that the old
languages the old cultures I mean the
Cherokee language Rebecca
Adamson can tell us here and the Bengali
language in India and a lot of the old
languages don't have gender they don't
have he and she people are people
what a concept you know so the question
is who is that child is a unique
individual because that child is the
result of of millennia upon millennia of
heredity and environment combined in a
way that could never have happened
before there could never happen again so
if we try to see you know who each kid
uniquely is then you know we'll have a
huge range sometimes I think that the
world is divided in two kinds of people
those who divide everything into two and
those who don't
and I think that we just have to cut
that out you know - stop stop dividing
everything into two and
masculine/feminine it's made up it's
[ __ ] you know that's the irony that
that's the big irony of where we are
because on the one hand gender doesn't
exist race doesn't exist class doesn't
exist caste doesn't exist in real terms
the individual difference is bigger than
the group difference but we are born
with brains
you know much smaller I don't know
what's up 85% of our brains or something
developed after birth and this makes us
incredibly influenceable you know the
the good news is that we're adjustable
and the bad news is that we're
adjustable but if we can just keep a
grip on two thing on these things at the
same time that these categories don't
exist but they're very real to us
because we have grown up with them and
we have the fun of challenging them and
stretching them everyday and trying to
figure out who we uniquely are and
support other people in who they
uniquely are and I think we're seeing
this much more aren't we I mean with you
know gender is much more out the window
than it ever was when I was growing up
then you know people changing gender
people changing alright okay I'm gonna
stop there but I'm just so worried about
what's gonna happen tomorrow because we
met tonight okay so
so if if you don't have to do anything
I'm about to suggest you don't have to
do anything you don't want to do but if
you came here I bet you share interests
and values and who knows so if you try
introducing yourselves to three or four
people you don't know before you leave
and say what you're doing but you care
about you know what's coming up that
needs help what you know and who know
who knows what might happen is the
result of all of us being here tonight
who knows let's come back a couple years
from now and find out how this was a
huge point of change thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is there an on